notre vue exclusive encore une fois les
essais privés
il ya deux parce qu'il l'a non dit l'uci
vous m'avez bien faire et on à votre
rôle de guilin dans l'émission 9.5 je
dois vous avouer là que je t'ai pas mal
femme de l'émission moi aussi je veux te
dire que chaque fois que je regarde les
sketchs qu'on a fait et des sketchs que
j'ai pas regardé depuis presque dix ans
et il me fait rire encore parce que vous
êtes avec angelo cadet on dirait que
vous êtes deux vieux pirate
c'est ce qu'on est on est encore des
amis on s'appelle être les semaines pour
l'un des projets encore en forme
on a proposé d'autres projets étrange
qui n'ont pas été mais on a encore des
brigades et je suis votre carrière
depuis vos tout début depuis votre
sortie de l'école à cette date en 94 on
vous a vu dans le lecteur de dominic
champagne s'agirait là aussi je vous ai
vu vous avez goûté la rançon de la
gloire avec votre personnage de bob au
canal famille dans une galaxie près de
chez vous sk encore aujourd'hui on vous
en parle
et quelle phrase ou souffle-t-on à
l'arrêt pas su des phrases cultes dans
cette émission l'a dit c'est drôle mais
quand je vois guillou je pense toujours
à la théorie capitaine simplement comme
ça dit reste notre capitaine toulousain
porte oui c'est sûr que bob avec cheveux
cela frappe comme ramène le plus souvent
ou et bad avec cheveux la bonne c'est
assez étrange parce que moi je n'avais
jamais pensé que c'était drôle
vous avez en être prisonnier de bob
abbey monté j'ai cru qu'on allait s'en
sortir mais il ya eu les reprises puis
bon il faut faire un commando de films
avec ses avis lancé c'est fini en 2006
j'avais réussi l'exploit en adoptant le
rôle titre dans pure laine à télé québec
c'est je pense un des premiers rôles ou
juste un comédien noah avait en route
oui c'est important pour vous je pense
séparés à nivea s'est pas réalisé on
verra bien mais c'est ça c'était comme
un ovni aussi ces objets et un pylône
est un petit peu en avance sur son temps
avec les thématiques abordées puis ça
pourrait revenir mais ils écriraient le
même texte à votre et rendent l'on vous
croyez encore un bon bout de chemin et
enfin il ya un bon bout de chemin à
faire encore ouais non car comment ça
depuis deux ans je disais j'ai
l'impression que
il ya des gens qui est des friches
d'autres terrains tranquillement
tranquillement c'est comme ça mais
croyez-vous à la discrimination positive
dans les andes à sens bien je pense que
en quelque part on n'a presque pas le
choix baptiste même chose pour les
femmes c'est c'est le balancier c'est sa
part été pas mal en fait plombs ça va
aller trop loin quand tu fais avant de
trouver l'équilibré et ça prend un
certain salaire
vous avez déjà abordé la question mais
vous avez eu un passage à vide après
2006 après pure laine justement comment
vous avez vécu tout ça il reste toujours
une petite espérance en quelque part que
peter jackson d'appel puis il fait se
dit fasciné trilogie de tourner pendant
des mois et bien moi sur un fil il
resterait c'est toujours ça peut pas
partir
donc on a toujours cette cire est bleu
on le dit pas mais il s'est fait que
pendant ce temps leur jeu capable de
vivre dans l'appartement dans lequel je
me suis bien comme ça j'ai pas besoin
depuis lens j'ai besoin d'avoir deux
hélicoptères je suis bien méchant vous
savez un deuxième capteur pile
lamborghini il ne dirait pas non
vous êtes vraiment sur une superbe
lancer parce que venant lacéré appelle
moi si tu marques 2010 qu il est en
répétition à ce moment au théâtre du
rideau vert pour le malade imaginaire
mais en fait votre patient sur pays
parce qu'on peut rien dire mais l'an
prochain nous allons avoir deux gros
rôle
donc pour vous c'est la récompense la
côte c'est magnifique ça arrive au bon
moment je trouve parce que je pense que
si j'avais eu siro les héraultaises qui
s'en viennent pour moi je rappelais
j'étais trop jeune
là maintenant j'ai besoin d'avoir une
certaine maturité d'avoir un comme un
radar aussi une envie de dire
à des choses plus profondes où c'est qui
paye c'est payant pour moi pour vous
prépare à ce moment-là vous achetez un
hélicoptère
je suis un petit hélicoptère et des
chiens
merci beaucoup l'hélicoptère